-Our first guest tonight is
a best-selling author
and comedian whose new comedy
special, "Revolution,"
will premiere
on Netflix December 27th.
Please welcome back to the show
one of our favorites,
Chelsea Handler, everybody!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Funk plays ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
It's so lovely to have you here.
-Oh, my God, I'm always happy
to be with you, Seth.
-And it's kind of --
it was maybe a little angsty
the beginning of last week
and here we are, you know,
six days after the midterms.
How are you feeling?
-Oh, God. Well, you know,
I'm a staunch Republican.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And you keep your spirit up.
-I know. I'm so woke that
I've become a Republican.
[ Laughter ]
I was pretty excited.
You know,
it's a pretty exciting time.
It's been a long time
since I've watched an election
where I was like surprised
and hopeful.
And then there are
just so many doorknobs
that are also involved in this
election, like Herschel Walker
-Yeah.
-and Lauren Boebert.
And I'm just like Republicans
have completely lost the plot.
So, to see them
actively losing their ground
and thinking about just Trump
pacing back and forth
at Mar-A-Lago just gave me
so much joy.
-I did have empathy for --
[ Laughter ]
for Tiffany Trump
on her wedding day,
that that was when --
I think Nevada was called
while he was probably
at the wedding.
-Yeah, but she was -- I mean,
for her to get married
at her father's place
was a mistake, to begin with...
-Yeah.
-...because, I mean,
it's not like --
I'm sure he charged her,
you know?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-So why?
I mean, she's not
thinking things through.
She's marrying some guy
who comes
from a very rich family.
She needs to cut ties now
and just be done with him.
If anything,
she should've scheduled
a wedding at Mar-A-Lago,
but had the real
wedding elsewhere, right?
[ Laughter ]
Get him going to the place.
-Yeah.
Because he would've stayed there
and it would've taken hours
before he realized
the wedding wasn't happening.
[ Laughter ]
-But also, can you imagine
trying to celebrate with him
about anything,
even if he was in a good mood?
I mean, this is an opportunity
for her to find
her real birth father, you know?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now that she's married,
she can sever ties
and go live a full life
where she's treated like,
you know, not a marginalized
member of a family.
-That's a very -- This is --
See? This is good advice.
And I want to draw attention
to the fact that it makes
natural sense to me that you're
good at advice.
You started a podcast
where you're now
giving advice to people.
-I do.
I like to give advice,
whether it's solicited
or unsolicited.
[ Laughter ]
-I think that's what everyone
appreciates about you --
-You know?
-you don't have to ask.
You just give it.
-No, yeah.
I mean, and I love to like
give girls a little bit
more power
when you're feeling insecure.
As women, we go through so many
different phases of our lives
where we feel self-confident
and then
we second-guess ourselves.
And I'm just like I want women
to be empowered, you know?
Also, when you see something,
to say something, you know?
And I use a story
that I like to tell
as a guideline for all people,
you know, to say something,
even if it's
a very awkward situation.
-Okay.
-I once accidentally had dinner
with Woody Allen and Soon-Yi.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
How does that come about
by accident?
-Well, I blame Katie Couric
because she's the one
who invited me out that night
and then, before I knew it,
I was sitting across
from Soon-Yi and Woody Allen.
And, as a woman,
knowing what I know,
that was hard for me.
I wasn't -- I was like,
"I don't trust myself,"
because I can't really be
respectful, you know?
[ Laughter ]
And I didn't know what was going
to come out of my mouth,
if I was going to be able
to control myself,
but I was like, "Just wait,
you know, like wait your time
and just bide your time
and just, you know,
be pleasant and be respectful
during this dinner encounter."
And I waited and I was patient
and I exercised patience.
And then dessert came and they
put down a blackberry cobbler
in front of Soon-Yi and Woody
and Woody went to take a bite
out of the blackberry cobbler
and I leaned in and said,
"How did you two meet?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's real patience.
That's an assassin's patience.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I slept like
a baby that night.
You know what I mean?
I was just like,
"You know what?"
And then Katie's like,
"Okay, Chelsea, time to go."
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah, but I feel like
women need
to always be able to because,
if I had left that dinner
and I hadn't said anything,
I would've been so pissed
at myself for years to come.
So, I think, you know,
I'm a good big sister
and I want everyone to succeed
and I just want everybody
to be a little smarter
and a little braver.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Well, those are --
that's wonderful advice.
You you went out --
We were talking backstage.
You toured this hour.
You have a new hour
that's coming out soon,
called "Revolution."
-"Revolution," Netflix,
two days after Christmas.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Almost -- was it 100 cities
or thereabouts?
-Yeah, I did about 100.
I did about 120 days.
I'm still -- I'm finishing up
my last bit of this tour.
I'm actually headed to Florida,
so I can't wait to see
how that works out.
This weekend, everybody.
All the Democrats in Florida,
I'm coming!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there's a lot of them.
-Come see me.
Yeah.
There's about four left.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah, I've been touring
and, I mean,
first of all, I love touring.
You love stand-up.
We both doing it.
-I do, yeah.
-Yeah.
-And you shot it
in Nashville, right?
-Uh-huh, yeah.
-That's a great comedy town.
-It's a great theater,
the Ryman in Nashville.
So, I loved -- You know, I had
so much material from COVID
and from just all the stuff
that happens during COVID,
you know, and all of like
just how we all behaved,
how embarrassing it was,
starting with yourself,
-Yes.
-you know?
I was Windex ing my food
up until recently, so.
[ Laughter ]
You know, and now,
you're just like, "What, COVID?
What's that?"
I was excited for monkeypox
to take off,
but that didn't seem --
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry.
I know you were real--
You were one
of the early investors.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I know.
It's just like Bitcoin.
It's just one big bubble.
-Yeah. Monkeycoin
did not work out for me.
[ Laughter ]
You actually talk a little bit
about being a businesswoman
at a very young age
in your special
and the fact that you started
a babysitting service.
-Oh, yeah. Well, when I was
ten years old --
I'm the youngest
of six kids, you guys,
so, when I was born,
my family was just like,
"You know, let her raise
herself, I guess."
[ Laughter ]
They were sleeping most
of the time
and they just had been exhausted
by my other siblings.
So, when I was ten, I took my
first plane ride to California
to visit our grandparents
and it was my mom
and like two of my brothers
and I had never been on a plane.
So, we walked past
the first-class section
and I was like, "Oh, like
who are these people," you know?
[ Laughter ]
And my mom's like,
"Never mind that, you know.
We have six kids in our family.
We can't afford that and we'll
never fly first-class."
And I'm just like,
"Speak for yourself," you know?
[ Laughter and applause ]
And we went to go visit
my grandparents.
We came home and I was like,
"I have to start a business,"
so I started
a babysitting company.
I was ten years old,
but I looked like I was 15,
so, I lied and said I was 15
and ended up babysitting
for kids
that were older than me.
[ Laughter ]
As a ten-year-old, I had
a regular client who was 14
and I was basically putting
this kid in time-outs
all summer long,
but I saved up like $3,500
and then the next time
we went on a plane ride,
it was three years later,
I was 13 years old,
and I had gotten a first-class
ticket from a travel agent
that lived down the street
and so,
when we boarded the plane
with my mother
and my two sisters, this time,
I saw my seat 2A and I said,
"See you guys
at the end of the flight."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I have a great deal more
to ask you.
We'll be right back
[ Cheering and applause ]
with more from Chelsea Handler.